[Musique]
plus que jamais les partis politiques
québécois s'exerce sur les médias
sociaux en vue des élections de 2008
vous avez aimé la vidéo
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'un ado vous
risquez de plus en plus de voir les
partis politiques à venir vers vous sur
votre compte facebook
sans que vous le souhaitiez
nécessairement ça fonctionne plus
d'avoir des messages qui sont génériques
avec nous on est pour la tarte aux
pommes le soleil au début du mois de mai
hitchcock la vraie stratégie derrière
pour les campagnes moderne si les
données c'est-à-dire en connaître plus
sur les électeurs qu'on essaie de
rejoindre les partis politiques peuvent
avoir accès à une foule de données sur
les électeurs et leur milieu leur âge
leur environnement social leur position
géographique et facebook permet aux
parties moyennant quelques dollars de
publier des contenus qui vont atteindre
public en particulier en fonction des
données
même s'ils ne sont pas suivies par ce
public mais c'est ce que des réseaux
sociaux ont vraiment par différents soit
au final je pense que oui si on a une
stratégie qui est basée sur la mise en
relation directe avec des nouveaux
électeurs qu'on travaille correctement
et dans un deuxième temps si on le fait
en essayant de le cibler
géographiquement pour munster j'userai
en étant la bulle de l'assemblée
nationale aux médias sociaux
c'est sur le point de changer récemment
facebook a rencontré le parti québécois
le parti libéral du québec et la
coalition avenir québec pour les aider à
optimiser leur stratégie
même si le pq une longueur d'avancé en
nombre d'abonnés
[Musique]
le nerf de la guerre semble en effet
ailleurs il ya beaucoup de trucs pour
aller chercher plus loin que nos cercles
ça peut être un passant par la
sonorisation du ciblage sociaux qu'on
fait la clé c'est le message le contenu
surtout chez les jeunes
qu'est ce qui fonctionne le plus un
message positif pour un message négatif
ça n'est pas qu'est ce qu'on veut faire
un message négatif fonctionne plus dans
l'immédiat puis pour imprimer quelque
chose dans la tête des gens qui marchent
le mieux avec les jeunes en ce moment
c'est vraiment des produits de parler
toujours parti québécois de formation
politique
je veux parler de ce sujet nrj12 mode
proportionnel sont les céréales à
rechercher davantage mais
ses dirigeants ont maintenant on est
rendu à faire de la politique
dix décennies la politique de contenus
qui les intéressent plus devant
l'élection c'est c'est vrai il a dit
qu'ils avaient besoin les jeunes
familles je te jeunes familles votent
pour lui c'est très clientéliste l'
avantage pour les partis politiques
c'est que ça coûte pas mal moins cher de
publier des contenus sur facebook que de
diffuser une publicité à une heure de
grande écoute à la télé une autre façon
de contourner les médias traditionnels
de passer son message directement
[Musique]